[Music]
welcome to iron Lords podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are live
Walcott needle here I'll or podcast
Lords of gaming dotnet and who is this
fine gentleman we have in the realm
today my name is Eric Schrader and the
community ambassador for rock fish
gamers awesome rock fish games in the
house now first day we have to talk
about right off the bat is this cool
game called ever space right
tell us about ever space - this is a
shooter like give us the whole deets on
ever space so in order to do that I am
gonna start with every space one first
to create a bridge to get the history
for giving us the instruments so
basically every space one ism is an
arcade a space shooter with a roguelike
formula so that means whatever you die
you have to start back over and do
everything again and it's all
procedurally generated environments to
keep things fresh keep you on your toes
very heavily skill based game I do
recommend it the more time you put into
it the more it gives back nice so now
that bridge goes like directly in outer
space - we are still an arc ad space
shooter however instead of a roguelike
it's an open-world RPG oh that's a huge
departure from the first two big change
yeah and so there's a lot of reasons why
we are doing this the long story short
is that it's a really proper
continuation but the story arc that we
have built from the events of ever space
1 moving into ever space - I'm not gonna
get spoilers sorry about this but never
space when you do play the role as a
clone and they're trying to figure out
why you were created what you're trying
to accomplish and like who you are all
these different things and they come
together it comes full circle at the end
of every space one and with this new
knowledge you've acquired when you start
into ever space - you're now trying to
define yourself as moon
trying to find your purpose okay okay
opens up into this open world RPG okay
just now this sounds amazing okay so
what I want to ask though is how are you
handling story progression the story
beats I mean with a shooter right
I would I would think that I would say
that it's completely impossible but
there have to be some challenges is it
like between stages we're doing like
they are we doing the whole narrative
during the game how are we handling the
narrative a story aspect story building
aspects of the game absolutely so we are
we're we've got a locked-in linear
storytelling about a twenty to thirty
our campaigns what we're shooting for it
which you can break away from at any
point in time okay and say I want to go
explore that planet over there I want to
go to a completely different solar
system or I want to test my guns against
that really big ship off in the distance
Wow and you're gonna make those
decisions that are gonna give you
experience leveling up your pilot and
also giving you new opportunities and
new gear that you're finding which by
the way is our itemization is entirely
like a diablo and space experience all
of these different rich and modifiers
and attributes yeah I can completely
change up the way you're playing finding
a new energy core new weapon okay nice
okay we got a lot of that so a little
bit of randomization of their different
things that loop that you pick up that
will give you different attributes that
help out on the ship
okay so we got Diablo and space a little
bit a little open were okay now break
down the open ones so in a sense of
theirs in the beginning there's a linear
path kind of to get the player
acclimated but then you can but still
you could open up at any point okay
so then from there is it you know you
have that freedom but how do you advance
the story is the game giving you cute
clues to advance so say hey this is
objective one that you need to focus on
to the next day how's that handled this
great question so the big thing is that
we want to really focus in on making
sure the player has the direction to
move forward at any given time so when
you complete objective a they will
naturally assign objective B for the
very next task
but you can just click a button that
says I don't want to look at that on my
screen gotcha
I wanna go do my thing and then when
you're like okay I'm gonna press the
story you turn that thing back on and
you had four objectively okay with those
with those side missions and things like
that is it'll allow you to like
essentially have extra side missions in
addition to have that one linear story
you have absolutely the side missions
will open up for not only yourself to
develop new abilities and attributes and
also find unique equipment that you can
only find by doing those side missions
you will also end up encountering new
companions and mission chains that they
would only be able to provide you by
stretching yourself out and going
exploring and doing all those now tell
me about campaigns so these are like
NPCs that will assist you during combat
and or adjust people that you just come
across okay if ever space is providing
these options then why they're so with
the story specifically that's where
you're gonna see these companions start
showing up though you're meeting along
your path okay and in some cases they
will join you for the missions that you
are challenged by now and in other cases
you just say hey you know what hang out
at the home base I'm gonna go do my
thing
I'll be back alright nice do that now do
you allow for like multiplayer like but
if you donate I'll help and you got call
a friend up be like hey can you come and
join us is that something that you guys
please so this is strictly like or a
single-player story or is it a lot for
multiplayer so we are entirely focused
as a single-player experience it's the
way we want to be we don't we really
don't want to go into a multiplayer
territory you know we've had a lot of
people saying it would be so great if
you did that we don't disagree it's just
not what our vision okay fair enough
fair enough we respect that so again now
as far as the basic [ __ ] ship combat by
just moving around things of that nature
right so what is what are our basic guns
towards what are we doing oh yeah so
yeah you have a lot of different
opportunities to
diversify your weapon portfolio okay if
you work away what we work away yeah so
with ever space one we introduced a lot
of different weapons including the
Gatling gun you know your pulse laser
your memes we had stuff like a neutron
cannon that was a lightning gun okay a
plasma thrower who need who needs a
flamethrower on space we do so you're
welcome for that it's wonderful and
we're gonna see the adaptation of a lot
of those weaponries combined with unique
attributes and modifiers because that
diablo style system that's gonna
transform like even two different pulse
lasers could theoretically be entirely
different from one rule that's where
that random lo factor comes the the
attributes from the weapons and things
you're talking about are those things
that are a hundred percent generated
like on the fly or they like
pre-designated like the Gatling gun only
allows like XY and z different abilities
yes that space is that because you're
going out and doing your own thing you
are gonna find a lot of randomized loop
that's just completely
random but there's also gonna be those
missions that you if you're very set on
very intentional about completing you'll
be rewarded with very set statistical
games for certain equipment so for
example a legendary pulse laser for
example the only way you can get it is
if you complete a very specific mission
chain and that legendary pulse laser
will always have very specific
attributes associated with gotcha
so right now rockfish games again we got
the sequel but his new Direction is
robust ambitious title
where are we at right now in development
and then also um what do we work what
are we working with engine-wise to the
game looks phenomenal Unreal Engine 4
school yeah we're really pleased with
the results it's been it's been a fun
process and development wise we are
still very heavy work in progress so
getting it really close to our alpha
okay so from our alpha 2 beta access
early access is a really important one
okay because our doors are gonna be
opening up wide and oh man for the
masses our Outlander banner closed off
only to our Kickstarter backers fair
enough these are the supporters you got
to respect the day one's really gotta
respect the day one so with early access
that's gonna be about September okay end
of this year awesome
development time is about one more year
from that point to for release so we
have a lot of time to work with you guys
all your ideas are and match them to our
vision to create not just a good game in
our eyes but a great game together now
from the ambition aspect of the
Kickstarter our platform right now we
stick in the PC and then maybe with the
potential to go to console in the future
or it's just strictly PC as well we
reach our goals
so with outer space 1 we kind of had
that launch of PC first and then
consoles later yes we want to mix that
so we are aiming for a PC Mac Linux Xbox
one PlayStation 4 at release you just
touched my heart right because as a fan
of this genre
I feel the console space doesn't have
enough I grew up with games like they
when I first saw they remind me of a
game dad is departed 3do called total
eclipse and basically it was a stressful
dynamics game space shooter but then I
felt some more story beat aspects I felt
a little
we can command I've got a lot of
different beats in it and I definitely
think it has a ton of potential so I'm
really looking forward to developing
this game you guys got me excited I
cannot wait back the kick start where
could they go for the kicks where can
people do to support the game you know
that really want to get information on
this game absolutely there's a lot of
different ways that you can like
actively get involved I think the best
ways are really going to like our
discord believe it or not and just
hanging out and talking with us
this is huge it's transforming and the
more you contribute the more we're
inclined to like figure something out we
also do stream every Friday except up
tomorrow cuz we're here we stream every
Friday and will stream to watch the
stream what's the plants which give a
sure YouTube steam where everywhere okay
it's wonderful and this is under
rockfish all the people would have not
what people would know I can even like
put this there we go a lot of different
places you can go to like hang out get
involved with us the community here too
because with outer space one that
transition for us the community is what
really helped build this massive
experience that not only buttered it for
us but obviously for the community at
large
lowly absent we're using that same
formula with how we're addressing our
space to it it's it's a necessary
component to game development awesome I
love the community involvement I love
that they're taking feedback
I love the progression from the first a
lot of potential here we're looking
forward keeping our eyes out on it man
again you heard it here first ever space
to the sequel I'm Laura pocket has
approved so far we're gonna keep an eye
on this an absolute pleasure to have you
in the round thank you so much and open
up our trail
ever space y'all
you
[Music]